what do you appreciate though watching
now
watching all these episodes back what's
one thing that you've learned
i i now get it
i i get what a big hit it was i mean i
i didn't really understand the whole
like before sons michael i was oh you're
you're the guy from black hawk down oh
you're that guy from open range oh
you're the guy on goon the last boys
yeah the last boys you're that guy but
then you do
a show like sons for me
and the the level of what i hit that
thing was and what crazy show it was i
became kim coates so i i think after
watching the shows now that theo and i
have done i now understand the
incredible fandom that we and you know i
don't know if you know this michael but
sons is one of the only shows ever that
our our our ratings never went down they
they only went up like up and up they
never plateaued they never they just
went up from season one to two all the
way
fx is the biggest hit they've they've
ever had by a gazillion dollars so
pretty proud of all that when you were
doing smallville
it would remind me was it every week you
weren't binging yet right back then
right it was once a week it was once a
week there was no binging you had to
wait
yeah so i think that's part of sun's
success in a way we only did 13 every
season and when it opened in september
it was always that you know early
september uh 10 o'clock tuesday night
it just you know for the next 13 weeks
if you're a sons fan
you never missed a tuesday night and
then you had to wait
seven or eight months before the next
season so it's just talk talk chatter
chatter so i think that's one of the
reasons why our show
just continued to climb and build
because
you know
was it was it exhausting did were you
did you work every day were you
constantly like oh my god i'm exhausted
like you know like what were your days
like hey you know michael you you i'm
sure you're the same i i i'm allowed to
complain because i'm old now
but i never i never took for granted how
how much we worked or i never complained
yeah it was some really tough days we
we you know we're all in leather and
riding those bikes and those harleys and
we shot in like july august september
which you know in l.a is really really
hot and we we called it we called it
doing the timber
at least once or twice a week we go
timber man down
one of the crew would just [ __ ] pass
right out gatorade infusion of gatorade
because it was so freaking hot really um
yeah you were in lather and you were
riding motors did you have to learn to
ride a motorcycle for sons of anarchy or
did you already know how to do it no
there was only three of us who could
ride mark boone jr
uh david labrava and myself of the leeds
knew how to ride some of them lied and
said they did and then they fell a few
times and realized well you're a liar
so they all had to go to bike schools
everybody and i would say by the end of
the seven seasons charlie hunnam
probably became the best rider because
he was never off his bike he rode to
work every day we all did but he really
did and uh
yeah i know he became a really good
writer so yeah i know i knew how to ride
and i i was called safety first michael
because i would stop so many shots i go
cut
cut flanagan why are you rubbing your
[ __ ] feet on the ground because my
boots are slippery well you do that
later wait dll why are you zipping out
of the other line you got to stay caught
cut so they were really pissed off of me
but at the end i got a little trophy
from everybody calling safety first
probably saved a lot of lives when
you're on a harley there's no [ __ ]
around as you know it's it's the real
deal